[Music]
bo is with us in miami hey bo how are
you
i'm good dave i'm like so freaked out
that i'm on air right now
okay it's okay we've never lost a
patient yeah he sounds pretty good
this is crazy okay uh
yeah i'm bo i'm in miami i currently
make
35
000 i work for a non-profit that i
really really love
and they just called me and asked me if
i'd be willing to continue working for
them but in a different state
and i'm torn because this is really what
i want to do
and i like the work but
it doesn't line up with the amount of
money i make doesn't line up with paying
off my debt in two years
so
i don't know what to like i'm torn about
whether i should go with the career and
like really let like that be what drives
me or whether i should stick to the
numbers and then work it out after that
i really want to be that free actually
as possible but i would like to find
that free 4 30 maybe not good how old
are you
25 okay and you're going to pay off the
debt in two years if you stay in the
current situation making 35 000 no no no
what i make right now 35 is not going to
get me that in two years i've already
paid off 23 000
and i have 59 000 to go okay well fan
first of all fantastic so how much money
do you calculate that you would need to
make to be able to pay off the debt in
two years or even less what's that
number
that's like 70
000. that's almost 70 000 and i already
do like full-time work with the
non-profit so
right what are you and you're making
you're making 35 000 with this
non-profit so another 35 000 really like
37 sorry 37. okay great well here's the
deal if if i just want to give you an
alternate
uh narrative for a second if you were to
go get a 70 000 job and in this economy
you can right now you probably could if
you're qualified or you could get there
you could make that money you could also
get a side hustle
a good you know second job and really
bust it and you could get there and make
that kind of money
but if you weren't doing this work that
you love
you wouldn't be able to do that for very
long you could do it long enough to pay
off that debt and then get back into the
nonprofit world that is a viable option
but you have to be okay with that or you
can stay there and work for this this
organization that you really really love
doing the work that you know you're
supposed to do and then you just bust it
and you work hard you really just cut
cut cut cut cut in every waking hour uh
at 25 years of age that you're not doing
that work you love you're doing work you
have to do and i think you can get there
so i think you've got a couple options
there how about a third option oh here
we go where we find something that pays
70 or 100 000 a year that you love doing
that is a viable option as well it's not
just the nonprofit why do you have to
make less to love what you're doing i
don't understand this concept i don't
think you should make more doing what
you love
yeah
and part of me thinks like maybe that
what is it about your work that you love
well i love that i get to share the
gospel and i love that i get to like
really work with people like better help
communities like respond to the needs
of people around them that's very cool
so do i yeah
yeah and i make a lot more than 35 000.
yeah and i share the gospel every day
yeah i just i've never been offered like
a job while i have a job
and so
it's kind of hard for me to think about
i'm not i'm not challenging the job i'm
just saying that i think the things that
you are doing could be done a lot of
different the things that jazz you could
be done a lot of different ways and it
doesn't even necessarily have to be
under the heading of non-profit that's
correct
nonprofit's not in the bible nonprofit
is an irs designation
it doesn't make it holy or righteous
because it's non-profit it just means
they're broke yeah
so what we're saying is you're not
you're not destined to 35 000 you can
make more doing work that is ministry
related
and you can make more uh and i think you
will at 25 you're still very young but
but the reality is you've got some
serious options here i wouldn't say no
to this the general question the first
question was should i take this job i've
been offered an opportunity but it
doesn't make as much as i would like it
to make to pay off the debt as fast as i
want to pay it off right well she's
already in the 37.5 she's talking about
moving to another state and a similar
thing right at less money even yet well
cost of living and so um no i don't
think you can make it make the move to
the other state so
um
here's the thing what i'm trying to
shake up here and i'm being snarky to do
it which is my normal method
um is the the narrative the idea that a
you have to make less to do what you
love that's just not true it should be
the other way and b
that in order for you to be able to
share the gospel and minister in the
community that it has to be in a
non-profit setting or it has to be in a
setting where you don't get paid
anything
and none of that is true
those are not true narratives
and so you can
be a compassionate kind giving generous
person working in a compassionate giving
kind generous organization
uh that is christian based and sharing
the gospel and
there's a lot of places that he'll pay
more than thirty five thousand doing
that yeah and i wanna point out the the
the last piece of that though that if
you know let's take a teacher in our the
largest millionaire study ever done by
ramsey solutions third largest group of
net worth millionaires teachers median
salary the median in the united states
is 60 000. when you find that work you
love
you can still pay off debt and you can
still be
a millionaire but you're going to have
to live differently and cut your
expenses and you have to take a second
job from time to time to pay off that
debt so you know it's not about the size
of the salary it's what's my lifestyle
to do the work that i love
depending on the profession
beautiful thing about the generation of
people in their 20s
i think we call it the peace corps
generation because they have a heart to
serve the community
even if they have different belief
systems different faiths there's a heart
to serve it's beautiful